this video is brought to you by squarespace from
websites and online stores to marketing tools and
analytics squarespaces the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and run your
business check out squarespace through the link
in the description below and more on them in a bit
quick question how often have you seen a new
president enter office with a sack full of
promises only to immediately break the entire lot
of them well that number probably corresponds to
the number of presidents you lived under
from george h.w bush's no new taxes to
obama failing to close gitmo the white house has
a long tradition of over-promising and delivering
yet there was one president who bucked this
trend a man who on entering office promised four
specific things achieved them all and then
left after a single term that man was james
k polk and he was arguably the most successful
president in u.s history at the moment polk was
inaugurated in 1845 a movement was underway to
increase america's territory declaring that it
expands the nation westward polk quickly took
the u.s from a nation of 1.7 million square miles
to nearly three million it was polk who brought
in texas california oregon territory polk who
ordered the u.s to stretch from sea to shining
sea but all this giddy expansion came at a price
polk may have left the u.s greatly enlarged but he
also left it standing on the brink of catastrophe
the life james knox polk was born into on november
2nd 1795 was one for which only the term hardy
could suffice born in a log cabin in rural north
carolina polg was the first of an incredible
ten children all of whom his mother would raise
in a strict calvinist faith that meant little
fun and a lot of hard work as an adult polkwood
overworked to the point of exhaustion unable
to escape the feeling that arrest was somehow
wicked yet compared to the rest of his childhood
work was almost a respite when the boy was 10 his
family upped sticks and moved to the tennessee
frontier where his father was determined to
carve out a plantation for over 500 miles
the family traveled on rough roads via wagons
subjecting themselves to all sorts of deprivations
it was on this journey that the future president
began to suffer the ill health that would plague
him for his life and given how bad things got
actual plague would have probably been preferable
as a teen for example polk was forced to undergo
surgery for his illness with no anesthetic and
no antibiotics the surgeon simply gave him some
brandy and then sliced his urinary tract open
and sewed him back up all while the boy presumably
screamed still the move to tennessee did at least
change the family's fortunes the new plantation
grew to thousands of acres tendered by 50 slaves
as the polks came up in the world they began to
rub shoulders with the great and good of the state
the greatest of whom was no doubt andrew jackson
a living military legend old hickory was already
famous for his controversial wars and role
in tennessee's expansion he was also about
to become the biggest most divisive thing
in american politics in other words exactly
the sort of personality an ambitious young man
might want to hitch themselves to a young man
like james polk it's uncertain exactly when polk
and jackson first met but it can't have been long
after the young man returned from university in
north carolina initially settling in nashville
to practice law polk quickly set his sights on
politics picking up a side gig clerking in the
state senate it was here that he fell decisively
into the orbit of democratic republicans likely
the single most powerful party in u.s history
by 1823 the democratic republican party was
headed towards its seventh election victory in a
row a feat still unmatched in american politics
but as the party reached a quarter century in
power the lack of opposition had become a curse
fishers were starting to erupt that threatened to
engulf everything it would be from the ashes of
these political wildfires that polk's washington
career was born for now the future president
concentrated on local politics winning election
to tennessee's state house of representatives
there he made perhaps the shrewdest decision of
his life tennessee was in need of a new senator
to send to washington although he was aligned with
a different faction polk wound up casting his vote
for a grateful andrew jackson it seems the young
man was already able to read the political winds
within a year those winds had become an oncoming
storm in 1824 four different candidates claimed
the mantle of democratic republican nominee among
them was andrew jackson down in tennessee polk
campaigned ferociously for his new friend
delighting when he gains the largest share
of the popular vote but since none of the four
managed to win outright it held a congress to
pick the next president to polk and jackson's
outrage they went with second place finisher
john quincy adams yet the result would be a
blessing in disguise when the next election
rolled around old hickory would be able to
use outrage generated by adams's corrupt wind
to propel himself to the very top and his new
protege would be riding along right beside him
the same year he lost the presidency by a whisker
andrew jackson gave polk perhaps the best piece
of advice the young man would ever receive to get
married see the thing we haven't mentioned is that
james polk was a dude who was incredibly hard
to like austere dower prone to overwork awful
at conversation and uninterested in anything but
politics polk was like your nightmare tinder date
a sexless boring man who couldn't charm his way
out of a paper bag which is why his 1824 marriage
to sarah chadrus was such a gift the rich daughter
of politically connected slave owners sarah was a
born socialite the sort of woman who could work a
room so well that everyone would leave wanting to
do exactly as she had suggested as polk's wife
sarah used every ounce of this charm to help
nurture and expand her husband's tennessee power
base in no time at all that base was flourishing
in 1825 polk abandoned the state legislature
taking a run at the house of representatives
he won handily the first of seven terms that
it served in washington and that gave him
a ringside seat to the biggest electoral storm in
decades the 1828 election saw jackson's comeback
netting the victory denied four years earlier at
the head of the newly created democratic party
he crushed john quincy adams taking 55 percent of
the popular vote inaugurated the following march
jackson entered the white house like a hurricane
ready to smash the old order to pieces personally
james k polk couldn't wait rather than just
being jackson's ally in the house polk became the
seventh president's lieutenant the guy who'd go to
bat for him no matter what bat crazy thing jackson
was slinging every single idea that jackson
put forward polk defended to the hilt helping
whip his fellow representatives into following the
president his colleagues made fun of him calling
him young hickory made out that he was jackson's
puppet but polk was more than that it may have
been ambition that initially hitched him to this
brash populist but it was something else that made
him stay for polk jacksonian democracy wasn't just
an idea it was a movement a movement that actively
expanded the electorate that spoke for the
people and the people couldn't get enough of it
re-elected in 1832 jackson was by now starting
to consider polk the son that he'd never had he
backed his protege to become speaker of the house
before ensuring that polk would keep that position
even after he stepped down as president a promise
made easy when his hand-picked successor martin
van buren won in 1836. for polk this was an era
where he rode the zeitgeist to the crest of a
popular wave that looked set to keep rolling
for eternity also it must have seemed in truth
jackson's policies especially regarding banking
had set the economy on a crash course and his
divisive manner had sparked a massive backlash
in his home state in 1835 in 1837 anti-jackson
politicians won the tennessee governor's mansion
in 1836 the state voted against van buren worried
about the rebellion in his backyard polk quit the
house returned home and in 1839 ran for governor
on an openly jacksonian platform his shock win
was supposed to turn the tide to show this wave
was never going to stop sweeping the nation
instead polk's victory turned out to be a
mere breather before the wave dumped him naked
shivering and broken onto reality's stony shore
by 1840 the jackson experiment had failed the
economy was being hammered people were going
bankrupt and life tasted of ash and bitterness
that same year the whig party under william
henry harrison beat the democrats at the polls
just 12 months later polk was booted from the
tennessee governor's mansion when he tried to
retake it in 1843 he failed spectacularly with
jackson's movement floundering and the wigs and
ascendants polk suddenly found himself cast adrift
he returned to the family plantation wondering
if maybe that was it if his time at the top had
already come and gone he needn't have worried
in 12 months the wig's seemingly unstoppable
rise was going to splutter and stall and when it
did it would be young hickory could be ready to
replace them now just before we get into the rest
of today's video i do want to say that this one
is brought to you by squarespace this is the
age of creation think about it everybody is
out there on the internet making something online
whether it's a tick-tock dancer youtube video or
a fantastic website and look if you want to make
a fantastic website the right way to do that is
with our friends over at squarespace squarespace
is the perfect web tool to fashion the internet
into whatever you want it to be maybe the hands-on
type he's got lots of opinions and ideas about
what exactly your website should look like if
so very cool squarespace gives you all of the
customization options you could ever want with no
updates no patches no technical bs to worry about
nobody wants any of that nonsense or maybe you
just need something functional something that
works with minimal thought so that you can stay
focused on the content and not the coat of paint
if so just use one of their quick beautiful
templates to make a website that's both fresh
and simple and once you're done setting up
your website locking in the name maybe playing
with some of the colors there are so many extra
features that squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive email campaigns patronage
portals social integrations member-only areas
analytics commercial options 24 7 customer
support really everything you need is in
one place so when you're ready to get started on
next project of yours big or small if it involves
a website it's gotta be squarespace right now
you can go to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch your new site
go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics
and you'll say 10 of your first purchase of a
website or a domain and now back to today's video
at this stage you might be wondering how the hell
pog is going to transition from moping around in
tennessee to leading the united states in a single
year and the answer could be summed up with one
word texas seven years earlier texas had seceded
from mexico establishing an independent republic
not that the u.s wanted it to remain independent
though this was the era of manifest destiny a term
coined in 1845 that expressed americans desire to
expand westward starting with the annexation of
texas the problem was mexico still wanted their
wayward province back so rather than risk war
washington quietly avoided the issue but then john
tyler came along and screwed everything up the
10th president tyler had taken over from william
henry harrison after the latter died in office
nominally a wig tyler was such an unwick-like
president that his party hated him knowing
he'd never get re-nominated in 1844 tyler began
desperately casting about for a popular issue to
boost his run as an independent and nothing was
more popular than wanting to annex texas tyler's
pro-annexation stance effectively turned the
democratic party on its head beforehand martin van
buren have been expected to run again but tyler's
announcement made taxes such a hot issue that van
buren had to weigh in and that was a problem
because while van buren would lose southern
democrats if he came out as anti-annexation he'd
lose his home state of new york if he came out
as pro slavery you see was still legal in texas
if texas was admitted to the union the delicate
balance between slave and free states would be
destroyed van buren's one slim hope was to oppose
annexation then hope southern democrats after
a whole lot of moaning would rally behind him
rather than let the whigs win the election sadly
he misjudged how willing southerners were to play
nice with him at the 1844 democratic convention
the ballot deadlocked there was no majority for
anti-annexation van buren but his rival louis
cass couldn't quite win either on the eight ballot
someone suggested throwing in a compromise
candidate to break the tie someone known
for his party loyalty someone who might be i don't
know chilling down in tennessee right now only
dimly aware of all of this drama the moment polk's
name was added van buren knew that the game was
over rather than let cass become eventual victor
he threw all of his supporters behind the new guy
at 2pm on may 30 1844 polk became the democratic
nominee it would take word nearly a week to reach
tennessee it reached washington that same day
though thanks to a newly installed telegraph
and the dudes in washington found the whole thing
hilarious polk was such a nobody the newspapers
declared who is james k polk the whigs responded
by putting up their best man henry clay knowing
it to be a cakewalk sadly for clay it turns out
the answer to who was james k polk was one clever
son of a [ __ ] polk's genius was to embrace texas
annexation while also throwing northerners a bone
what if oregon territory then jointly administered
with britain also joined the union since any new
oregon state would probably be free the delicate
balance in congress would be preserved all while
fulfilling america's manifest destiny that tricky
needle threaded all polk had to do was sit back
and watch the opposition flounder unwilling to
annex texas all the wigs could do was try to
portray themselves as the anti-slavery party a
hypocritical position since their nominee owned
slaves it was this simple fact that spelled
henry clay's doom when the election results
finally came in polk could won the popular
vote by a mere 38 000 ballots one of the
narrowest victories in u.s history painfully for
the wigs clay lost just enough votes in new york
to the hardcore anti-slavery liberal party to
put polk over the top had clay won the state had
squeaked an electoral college victory age
just 49 polk was set to become america's then
youngest president in doing so he set the
entire nation on a collision course with destiny
so back in the intro we mentioned how polk entered
the white house with four specific promises
so well now might be a good time to get them on
our checklist for ticking off later the first
two you're already familiar with one annex texas
two take over the oregon territory the other two
were a little bit more obscure three lower
tariff rates and four establish an independent
u.s treasury short as this list was it was also a
tall order especially since poll had already said
he only wanted to serve one term if he wanted to
become america's most successful president polk
was going to have to act fast luckily where one
item was concerned at least congress was already
raring to go one of the very first things polk
did in office was to sign off on congress's joint
resolution to annex texas that paved the way for
the lone star state to join the union in december
1845 providing polk with an early win the eleventh
president then immediately turned his attention
to the other chunk of territory that he wanted
oregon back in 1818 the u.s and britain had agreed
to join the occupy oregon country modern-day
oregon washington idaho and british columbia
this had worked well for a couple of decades
but as more and more americans started flooding
in on the oregon trail and manifest destiny
slowly became a thing people began to wonder
well why why were they sharing this prime piece of
real estate with a bunch of limey douchebags when
they could just take it for themselves a movement
even sprang up to annex the territory all the way
up to what was then russian alaska's southern
border at the latitude of 54 degrees 40 minutes
spawning the jingoistic slogan 54-40 or fight in
his campaign polk had capitalized on this feeling
promising to take oregon territory with a year of
being elected but now he was actually president
that whole or fight bit it was starting to look
a bit drastic no one wanted a bunch of redcoats
marching down from canada and setting the white
house on fire again especially not when mexico was
clearly gearing up for a war over texas so polk
did the only thing he could he cut a deal dropping
the whole 54 degrees thing american negotiators
contacted the british wondering if they
might not accept a slightly less offensive border
with the british also super not into the idea of
turning the war of 1812 into an ongoing franchise
a deal was quickly reached oregon country would be
divided along the 49th parallel with a slight
deviation at the end to allow the whole of
vancouver island to remain in canada and that's
how without a shot being fired the modern pacific
northwest joined the usa the oregon treaty came
into force on june 15 1846 less than a year and a
half into his term and polk had already fulfilled
his second campaign promise well actually it
fulfilled all four the first half of 1846 also
saw polk first convince congress to lower tariffs
and then to establish an independent treasury his
other two major pledges but while the president's
program was technically complete he didn't have
time to celebrate by the time the oregon treaty
was being signed the texas issue had already come
to a head the united states and mexico were now at
war by the time the carnage ended the political
map of north america would have changed forever
in late april 1846 mexican troops crossed the
rio grande determined to deal with the invaders
in their nation's north it was now a few months
since texas had joined the u.s an act mexico's
leaders felt should have led to war but didn't
but letting texas go was one thing it was quite
another to let enemies occupy mexican soil at last
the mexican troops found the american intruders an
opening fire they killed 12 before retreating as
they slipped back across the river the soldiers
must have felt a sense of triumph americans had
occupied their soil and paid the price but that
wasn't how the americans saw it as far as they
were concerned mexico had just invaded texas at
the moment texas became part of the usa it had
a disputed border with mexico an area between
the rio grande and the news's river that both
side claimed as their own not long after texas
was annexed polk could send a special envoy to
mexico city to settle the border claim but it
also ordered troops into the disputed zone under
general zachary taylor for some this act is final
proof that polk deliberately wanted to provoke
a conflict if that's the case well he got his
wish two weeks after the ambush that killed 12 u.s
troops congress authorized war with mexico it was
the beginning of the mexican-american war but it
was no longer just about texas if it ever had been
under the guise of conflict polk was about to push
through one of the biggest expansions that the u.s
would ever experience back in 1845 polkadot
dispatched charles freeman west to survey some
land around mexican-owned alta california survey
in air quotes there because freeman was really
heading an invasion force come may 1846 that force
was lying low on the edge of mexican territory
steadfastly being brutally murderous dicks to the
local native americans when word arrived at their
april ambush without even waiting to confirm if
congress had declared war freeman led his small
force into california rallying white settlers to
his side as they marched by june 14th the tiny
mexican garrison protecting the entire departmento
had surrendered just a few weeks later the navy
appeared off the coast and declared california
u.s territory it would take another month or so
to iron out the details but america was at last
beginning to stretch from sea to shining sea
you can see here why some people think polk was a
tricky son of a [ __ ] he 100 knew about freeman's
planned invasion and it's extremely likely that
he triggered the war as a cover for it yet who
can argue with the results between december
of 1845 and july of 1846 the 11th president
added not just texas and oregon territory to
america's portfolio but also california and
there was still more to come over the next year
and a half mexico was comprehensively defeated
the disputed texas territory occupied its capital
attacked and its government overthrown if we ever
get around to launching a war or graphics channel
and spoiler alert that totally might be happening
we'd love to talk you through all of
the highlights from winfield scott's
march from veracruz to santa ana's hilarious and
predictable double crossing of well everybody for
today's story though you only really need to
know the outcome major history spoiler though
mexico lost in washington the jingoism
unleashed by mexico's defeat was so great
that some democrats called for polk to annex
the entire country serenity now the president
managed to deflect their demands but not by much
the 1848 treaty of guadalupe hidalgo exceeded
even the warmongerer's wildest expectations not
only did it set texas border at the rio grande and
organize a payment to mexico in exchange for
california it also contained provisions for the
u.s to take new mexico known as the mexican
session it increased the size of the usa by
one-fourth giving washington the modern states of
arizona nevada utah new mexico and california plus
bits of wyoming and colorado for polk the treaty
was its ultimate triumph it was now nearly four
years since it assumed the presidency four years
in which it fulfilled all his pledges and turned
manifest destiny into concrete reality shaw
had taken 63 000 dead in a nasty war sure it
cleared the way for a wave of indigenous
killings across newly acquired california
one that would grow so vast it's today considered
a genocide but from the president's perspective
it'd have been worth it america's future was
now secure sadly the same can be said for polks
when pog fulfilled his promise in 1848 to step
aside after one term it must have seemed like
he'd go down in history as one of the greatest
presidents for a while he did after all he'd
grown the country and won a war so why isn't
that the case anymore why did the last survey
of presidential historians in 2021 place him
18th on par with bill clinton for that you can
blame the massive pandora's box that polk opened
with his drive west the one that ruined every
president's reputation in his era the box marked
slavery there's no point sugar coating it james
pog owned dozens of slaves while he'd request
that they'd be freed in his will he never had
the moral courage do it himself of course polk
wasn't alone in this half of congress in this era
consisted of slavers and therein lay the biggest
problem as polk drove america worst both pro and
anti-slavery advocates began to wonder if this
wasn't all a scheme to bring in new slave states
and shut the abolitionists out of power as early
as 1846 flights were erupting in congress over
the new states with bills alternately banning
and expanding the south's peculiar appalling
institution the court between competing currents
in his own party and his own unsteady beliefs polk
tried weak compromises suggesting the missouri
compromise line be extended clear to the pacific
but such dithering made nobody happy by 1848
slavery had become the defining issue of the era
by paving the way for a host of new states without
settling the slavery question poll kelp pushed his
nation a step closer to the coming abyss while it
would take a string of failed presidents to lead
it over the edge there's no denying the polk's
failure to address this explosive issue undermines
his claim to greatness still as polk left office
he could look back on four transformative years
beyond his fulfilled promises there was the
creation of the department of the interior
the treaty signed with new granada modern-day
colombia giving the u.s right of way across panama
the first step towards the eventual creation
of the panama canal had overseen iowa and
wisconsin joining the union stabilized the economy
averted war with britain all heady important stuff
sure he had to watch as the whig party under
zachary taylor won the 1848 election but still
for a one-term wonder he was unequaled sadly
paul didn't get to rest on his laurels for long
ill from overwork when he stepped down polk
embarked on a vacation a tour of the south to
bask in the public's affection while in
new orleans the newly retired president
felt deathly ill most likely the result of
a cholera outbreak then gripping the city
thinking it was just a flare-up of his lifelong
problems polk cut his journey short and returned
to nashville there he died on june 15 1849 after
the shortest retirement in presidential history
fast forward to today and polk occupies
a weird space in the popular imagination
generally beloved by those who know of him
almost invisible to everyone else certainly
there's a lot to love how many other presidents
have willingly stood down after a single term
how many others have entered the oval office
with such clear goals and achieved all of them
yet for his personal integrity and intelligence
james k polk maybe falls short of being great too
let down by the slavery issue by the later
calamities he indirectly helped cause great or not
though pog was a visionary if you live in one of
the 13 odd states he brought into the u.s you're
still living that vision today because make
no mistake polk was massively consequential
whether we love him or we loathe him we
should all at least agree to remember him
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for watching